10 connais bien les problèmes que
doivent affronter les autochtones dans
le système de santé canadien
l'ag type de traductrice parce que de
nombreuses années ne comprennent
toujours pas l'anglais liles a souvent
entendu des commentaires racistes venant
même de médecins elle raconte que
médecin a déjà dit un malade que la
seule raison pour laquelle les jeunes
autochtones se rendent à l'hôpital
et pour mieux se droguer pour le grand
chef des communautés du nord du manitoba
le racisme est omniprésent selon grand
chef des villes rappeur les ennemis qui
ne parlent pas anglais sont
automatiquement étiqueté ivrogne le
rapport de l'institut way sli première
nation traitement de 2ème classe
s'attardent longuement au cas très
médiatisé de la mort de l'autochtone
brian sinclair qui a passé trente quatre
heures à l'urgence
en attendant des soins qui ne sont
jamais venus dans le rapport on soutient
que l'impact du racisme s'est avérée
fatale dans son cas une vérité selon lui
les racines du problème sont très
profondes
pour le docteur smaili cosignataire de
l'étude
la question du racisme est occulté dans
la société pourtant selon elle c'est un
phénomène très présent même s'il n'est
pas nécessairement intentionnel en fait
elle est associée
mais janet mari ajoute que cette
situation entraîne un traitement
discriminatoire des autochtones en
milieu hospitalier et que ce type de
racisme
demain le plus dangereux l'étude
souhaite un nouveau dialogue à travers
le pays pour que l'accès à la santé soit
le même pour tout le monde
louis filet pour fo cette étude vient
confirmer ce que disait le magazine
maclean's il ya deux semaines sur le
racisme à winnipeg envers les
autochtones
voilà on s'en rappelle une série
d'articles qui a dressé un portrait peu
flatteur du canada disant que le racisme
ici et maintenant pire que ce qu'on voit
aux états unis mais qui a surtout parlé
de winnipeg où la situation serait la
pire au pays notamment en raison de la
situation
autochtone cela crée tout une levée de
boucliers le nouveau maire de winnipeg
berenboom qui a dû organiser très
rapidement une véritable opération champ
pour finalement changer la tendance et
se montrer à quel point les winnipégois
sont unis et non raciste donc bref
vraiment une onde de choc ici un
électrochoc royal électrochoc
aujourd'hui on parle donc plus
précisément du système de santé
est ce que dit le rapport au fond c'est
que tout ça est ancrée dans des
politiques du gouvernement
oui ce qu'on dit c'est que ce qu'on
explique c'est que finalement les
disparités pour ce qui est de l'état de
santé des autochtones et des non
autochtones sa s'expliquerait finalement
par la manière où les politiques
gouvernementales coloniale à quel point
sont ancrées et bien d'enchaîner et ben
on parle notamment aussi des pensionnats
autochtones
les chercheurs qui ont effectué ses
recherches heures qui parle aussi
carrément d'un inconscient parti pris
pro blanc parmi les travailleurs de la
santé un parti pris finalement qui
nuirait à la santé des autochtones de
partout au pays
évidemment c'est un rapport qui va
donner plus de poids aux revendications
des premières nations qui veulent du
changement aujourd'hui
ben voilà de retournement en passant par
ce groupe qui demandait une enquête
nationale publique sur le sort des
jeunes femmes autochtones disparues ou
tuées il ya de plus en plus de voir qui
s'accumulent pour finalement dire que le
statu quo n'est plus une option et l'ont
toujours mans une valeur fondamentale du
pays qui bien sûr l'accès aux soins de
santé pour tous merci beaucoup
louis philippe derrien